there are different levels of misusing
charities and charitable donations and
Donald Trump has done many of them right
one is handing over a check for a
charity at a political rally you're sort
of using political donations I'm sorry
you're using charitable donations at a
political event not really supposed to
do that another example would be using
charitable donations to donate to
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi's
campaign to make an investigation into
scam riddled Trump University go away
that's another example as a reminder the
trunk foundation has been ordered to
stop all fundraising by the New York
Attorney General at the top of the list
of ways in which charitable
contributions could be misused would be
straight up just using charity money for
a political campaign and we now have a
new report from Real Clear Politics
which says that that is exactly what
Donald Trump did real clear clear
politics looked at a series of donations
that Trump made through his foundation
from 2011 through 2014 totaling 286
thousand dollars they all went to
right-leaning policy group so the
speculation is Trump starting to think
about running for president in a serious
manner started donating to right-leaning
policy groups years in advance of his
campaign and the analysis found that the
timing of the donations oh what a
coincidence happen to line up with
endorsements from groups or ser happen
to line up with speaking invitations to
conferences and events wait a second we
have a name for this don't we it's
called pay-to-play and if it sounds
familiar it should because it's what
Donald Trump has been accusing Hillary
Clinton of through the Clinton
Foundation for months and months now
without having any evidence for it other
than a tweet from The Associated Press
which has since been retracted and
deleted we already knew as previously
revealed by The Washington Post that
Donald Trump used foundation money to
buy items at charity auctions that he
personally kept this includes for
example a football helmet signed by
football player Tim Tebow why anybody
would want anything sign
by tim tebow I don't know more about
football discussion than what about
Donald Trump uh using money to purchase
portraits of himself think about that
the height of of of of being just an
arrogant dude is taking money people
have donated to you for charity and
using it to buy portraits of yourself
just to be clear this was not Trump's
money because Trump hasn't donated to
his own foundation since i believe it
was 2008 although i don't have it in
front of me so there are numerous
problems here realclearpolitics
discovered that the Trump Foundation
which is a 501c3 organization donated 10
thousand dollars to the family leader
which is a 501 c 4 organization which is
a politically organized political
activity is not allowed by 501 C 3
organizations and it goes even further
because the donation was not recorded
appropriately there's this thing in
accounting in tax law where certain
transgressions if they were done
accidentally are not considered criminal
but this is not one of those even if by
accident you don't properly record these
transactions that is a violation of tax
law so but that this is just not looking
good for Donald Trump the Donald Trump
tax situation has melted and mixed in
now with the Donald Trump charitable
donations scandal which involves
basically everything under the books
misusing charitable donations for
politics using charitable donations uh
to funnel money back into his businesses
and and his uh his kids businesses and
businesses run by his kids and this has
become it's sort of like if we consider
this the worst week of trumps campaign
were on day nine or ten of the worst
week of Donald Trump's campaign Trump
goes to these rallies and says the wall
with Mexico just got ten feet higher
Donald Trump's worst campaign week just
got ten days longer this is really
really really not looking good for Trump
III don't know what else to say if you
want to chime in Pat by all means and of
course we also know that trumped by
himself is not a very charitable person
now of course we know more if you're
his tax returns but he's been coined as
the least charitable billionaire yeah
that's in my list of ways in which Trump
has problems with charitable donations I
forgot to mention that many many many
donations that Trump sort of generally
touted were looked into by David
Farenthold he actually called a lot of
the nonprofit's that Trump at some point
claimed to have donated to many of them
said not only has Trump not donated to
us recently we have no record of him
donating to us period and that is very
very disturbing maybe his supporters
will care I don't know I I have very low
expectations at this point for whether
anything that Trump does or is
discovered to have done will influence
people who have committed to voting for
Donald Trump